hello everyone and welcome to round five
of the ftx crypto cup with a game that
uh starts off very very calmly and it
seems like nothing is happening they
even described that um in this manner uh
sort of uh you know a lot of trading
pieces you know going into the end game
fairly quickly but then all of a sudden
a moment of pure insanity as one of the
player describes it players described it
and the entire board just explodes so
let's dive straight into it it's a
fairly short game uh but uh you you guys
will enjoy it i'm sure so let's check it
out duda has the white pieces and he
opens with d4 we have knight to f6 c for
e6 and now knight to f3 sort of the
anti-nimso variation but still magnus
goes bishop to be for check the
so-called bogo indian defense bishop to
d2 and now just bishop captures uh on d2
a5 is very very popular here and also
bishop can go back to e7 but magnus goes
for the forcing bishop captures on the
two queen captures and now pawn to d5 we
have g3 by duda uh preparing to get to
his light square bishop and castle his
king to safety c6 strengthening the
center and now bishop to g2 we have
knight beat to d7 uh in the now castle
so you can see magnus has all of his
pawns on light squares and he has a
light square bishop so he will have to
figure out a way on how to uh
develop it for it to be the least
painful so the characters on c4 grabbing
the pawn we have pawn to a4 now stopping
b5 and here magnus castles we have pawn
to a5 duda grabs more space on the queen
side and now pawn to b5 allowing the a
capture some b6 alpha saw so a captures
and queen captures and now rook to c1 so
magnus for the moment up upon but it's a
double c pawn with white having this
beautiful diagonal all to himself also
the semi-open a file
is uh
that's basically compensation in itself
so rook to b8 now putting pressure on
the b2 pawn and now knight to a3 saying
you can have your b2 pawn i'm gonna
capture on c4 and i'm gonna have all of
these uh things that we've already
mentioned so here bishop to a6 by magnus
he could grab uh on b2 right away but
bishop to a6 better of course magnus
knows this as he prepared the line
knight captures and c for now bishop
characters we have rook captures and now
queen captures on b2 so a huge capture
fest uh queen captures rook captures and
now bishop to f1 defending the e-2 pawn
we have rooked the c8 magnus has to
defend one of these pawns so you could
defend the a7 point you could defend the
c6 pawn and everyone would probably
defend the a8 pawn as it's the outside
pass pawn but magnus goes for rook to c8
instead and okay duda grabs the a7 pawn
uh
i mean why not you already get a rook on
the seventh rank if this rule gets on
the seventh rank as well it could be
very ugly for magnus pawn to g6 creating
a bit of a breathing room for the for
the king and now rook back to c1 we have
pawn to h5 and now pawn the e4 duda
saying okay you can't really move your
knight because your knights are stuck
defending each other uh so rook to d8
now defending the knight preparing
knight captures on e4 but now rook
captures on c6 duda says all right you
can have my e4 pawn i'm going to grab
your c spawn knight captures on e4 and
now rook c to c7 so do that i made this
straight to get both of the rooks on the
seventh rank
and now that that can be extremely
extremely
uh hard to defend if if the knight moves
then you capture on f7 and you start
delivering checks then you you know just
get checkmated so here rook captures on
f2 magnus is not without counter play
and now a beautiful knight to g5 by duda
attacking the knight that is defending
the rook and you really don't have a
better move than knight captures on g5
this is what magnus plays do that wins
the exchange and now knight to f6
so for the moment the knight is
defending the f7 pawn
but what if pawn to h4 well it's not
really a problem it's pawn to h4 you are
removing the defender of the
of the f7 uh pawn but uh you we can
easily defend we can play knight to d5
first attack the rook or we can just go
knight g to e4 with check move the
knight with check it's nicely defended
and only after the king attacks the
knight for example king to f3 we can
continue checking knight to d to check
uh if the king moves we're going to
capture the bishop for example king
captures now rook fade defends the pawn
and even though it's uh two rooks
against the rook and knight magnus is up
upon white spawn structure is uh
shattered as you can see dude that has
two pawn islands magnus would hold this
without much uh much issue so here king
the e2 instead and now knight to d5 we
have rooked a d7 offering a trade of
rooks and the magnus declines rook to c8
and now with the rook and the open c
file and with the two knights so close
to the white king it could get very very
interesting so here h4 by duda finally
chases away the defender of the f7
square and now uh rook to c2 with check
and now you have to be very careful king
to d1 or king the e1 doesn't matter what
you play
ends in check made if king e1 we just
play knight to f3 checking the one and
knight to e3 will be checkmate so the
only move for duda after rook to c to
check is to go after the rook go up the
board king to d3 but now magnus just
plays knight to b4 with check and this
is where the game
really starts
uh here magnus really should consider
and he said this in an interview after
the game rook to c3 check and he just
forces a perpetual king he too rook to
see to check again you cannot go d1 or
even you get checkmate so you have to go
back and here we would see a draw by
repetition however after this knight to
b for check move uh duda manages to
escape with his king he plays king to e3
now magnus plays rook to c3 check but
now king the f4
and now what do you play here the knight
here is still hanging on g5 and uh
magnus really has to be careful here he
played rook to f3 with check as he found
a brilliant way how he can check me dude
as king and g5 the problem for magnus is
that this does not work the only way for
magnus to play this and it is uh
beautiful is knight to f3 now point
being that duda would have only one
winning move yeah to give you an example
if you play something like let's say
bishop to e2 you go after the knight uh
we can easily play knight captures on d4
and now after uh let's say rook captures
on d4 uh just uh e5 uh this checks the
king attacks the rook once you capture
an e5 knights the c6 check with a with a
beautiful triple triple fork here king
e4 knight captures an a7 and this would
be a draw or even if you don't want to
play rook captures on d4 you could start
grabbing on f7 doesn't matter knight to
d5 with check king to g5 now rook
captures and g3 with czech king the h6
incredible as it is black can survive
this uh now nice to have five way to
check uh only move rook capture on f5
and after this is played g captures on
f5 bishop captures on h5 king to f8 as
uh you you don't want to get checkmated
with rook to a8 so we have to play king
to f8 now let's say rook to f7 check
king to g8 rook to a7 again we would see
a draw by repetition so after this
knight to f3 move the only winning move
for do that would be bishop the g2 and
here he would be able to acquire a
winning position uh now the knight is
hanging let's say knights to d3 with
check forces king captures on f3
otherwise the white will get in trouble
so king captures knight
c5 check opens up a discovery he goes
after the rook on d7 king f4 knight
captures rook captures on d7 and you get
this end game where duda would be up a
full piece magnus would be up a pawn
with perfect play maybe some sort of a
fortress is possible but very very
unlikely uh so that's uh definitely in
the position however like i said after
this
uh king to f4 move magnus did not play
knight to f3 he went for the spectacular
rook to f3 check move uh giving up the
knight here and the duda captures the
knight and now you're probably thinking
well now okay now he obviously captured
the bishop but not really here if he
captures the bishop king the h6 and now
uh well now you just get checkmated
there's no way to defend this whatever
you play it's just checkmate if knight
to c6 trying to help out with the knight
just rook to a8 to check and after you
block with the knight doesn't really
matter where we can capture with either
brook and this will now be checkmate so
uh after king captures and g5 magnus
played king to g7 beautiful move
preventing judas king from infiltrating
via king to h6 and now uh duda is in a
lot of trouble because now magnus is
threatening a rook to f5 checkmate there
is only one move that stops this and
luckily for duda it's not a difficult
one to spot bishop to h3 and now magnus
played knight to d3 and now you can see
what magnus is attempting to do magnus
wants to play knight to f2 which comes
with a tempo on the bishop and then
deliver knight to e4 checkmate so can do
to stop this it's not an easy position
to solve feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only winning
solution for duda while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on making your way
through this moment of pure insanity and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is pawn to g4 a weird move
to make yes but it is the only way to
make a room for your king uh you want to
capture and free up the g4 square for
your king and now what do you play here
with magnus it's uh
it's a terrible position to be in
because if you go for rook captures here
then rook captures an f7 and you get
checkmated king to g8 or whatever uh
we're just going to play king captures
on g6 and now after one more check is
given uh we're just gonna capture that
knight that's the only move and that's
it now you just get checkmated
there's uh no no actual way to play this
just rook to g7 checking h8 and rook to
f8 will be checkmate so that's out of
the question the other thing that magnus
can play and that's probably the thing
that he
had had planned for is knight to f2
again the thread is knight here
checkmate so how can dude stop this well
g captures on h5 again uh he clears up
the g4 square for his king and now this
is no checkmate so you have no better
move than to capture the bishop here uh
so knight captures on h3 with check king
to g4 now attacks the knight uh ended
the rook and not knight to g1 now the
knight defends rook and it seems magnus
survived this however h captures on g6
now threatening rook captures on f7 so a
king captures on g6 luckily the f7 pawn
is still defended but now duda wins with
the very simple h5 check and
interestingly this is again the only
winning move if you hurry up with
something like rook to a1 to put
pressure on the knight so you can
capture the rook uh look at this f5
checkmate uh so it's uh it's absolutely
incredible that the duda was so calm
in this position to even spot this so of
course he played h5 first he kicked away
the king away from his king and after
magnus played king to g7 he played rook
to a1 and he was in this position on
move 38 that magnus carlson resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here there is no counter play here the
knight will fall if you move the knight
the rook will fall so there's nothing to
play here and
f5 now is of course impossible as the
king is on g7 so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it magnus describes the
game as a moment of pure insanity uh
when he played this knight to be for
czech move instead of going for rook to
c3 a repetition of moves
but you know try to see all of this with
that duda found and it was the only way
to win this position so duda played it
absolutely brilliantly uh and that's uh
why he's one of the strongest players in
the world and why he was one of the
candidates in defeated candidates
tournament uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank raymond rafael uh boontyarkpung
ammar
mihal sakarias and charles bartholomew
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the ftx crypto cup until it
finishes thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day